[Music]
nothing says Britain more than nope nope
keep going oh yes there it is a nice cup
of tea
[Music]
we know we have China to thank for
introducing tea to the Western world but
how did it make its way to England and
become the cultural obsession is today
well that's all thanks to one Portuguese
woman the year 1662
the person Catherine of Braganza she
just won the hand of England's King
Charles the second with the help of a
very large dowry including money
treasures and spices this worthwhile
trade made her the Queen of England
Scotland and Ireland when she arrived to
her new homeland she brought with her
packets of loose leaf tea in crates
labeled transport Dervis aromatic us
it's a theory that this was later Berube
ated to te a t now t could all be found
in england but was only really used for
medicinal purposes catherine continued
drinking tea to her heart's content and
as the new royal everything about her
including her beverage habits was copied
by other ladies desperate to be just
like their idol
another thing catherine brought to the
table from portugal was the idea of tea
drinking experience she popularized the
use of porcelain tea cups and mugs but
the end of the 17th century much of
British aristocracy were enjoying the
hot beverage and soon enough so was
everyone else today while tea can be
found pretty much everywhere it remains
a special daily pastime for Brits hmm
so carry on and drink tea people of
England
[Music]
a legend around this chalk is that it's
impossible to write a false theorem
I assume the special ingredients where's
angel tears mathematicians from all the
top schools very frequently is it it's a
cult favorite as soon as I used it I was
a convert the chalk is one of the
best-kept secrets in the math world it's
the rolls-royce of truck
[Music]
hagoromo is a brand of Japanese chalk
the way it flows on a board is a bit
hard to describe in words it's really
hard to get only get it from Japan you
need a Japanese person to bring it back
for you I discovered it when I went to
visit the University of Tokyo and one of
the professor's there said to me you
know we have better chalk than you do in
the States and I said oh go on chalk his
chalk and so I tried it out and I was
surprised to find that he was right I
tried it I thought was phenomenal it's
the densest it erases the cleanest that
leaves the nicest line if you use bad
chalk often you've depressed really hard
for anyone to see what you're writing
so using hagoromo on a good board it
doesn't really feel like you're working
hard to write when I'm teaching I get a
feeling of energy confidence and the
chalk absolutely helps slowly the math
world has become aware of this and it
became a bit of a fad in some circles
it was like maybe four years ago the
word came out that the company was going
out of business
I sort of jokingly referred to it as a
chalk apocalypse so I immediately
started hoarding up as much as I could I
order three boxes of hagoromo and kept
in my office and used it very sparingly
I should have bought more but I have
friends have bought boxes and boxes and
boxes of the stuff they might very well
be set for the rest of their career
we felt like 1506 that's a lot of days
four sticks a day I think I'm gonna make
it I have probably a ten your supplies
still at home
buy calculated how many boxes what I
need to last for 10 or 15 years I didn't
want to become a talk to you later but I
did like the idea that I could be the
first stick is free chalk dealer on the
block in my department I was probably
selling it regularly to maybe eight to
ten colleagues I would reach into my
cupboard in my office and pull out
another box and we do the deal in my
office and we all had a chalk fix and we
still do the original hygroma chalk is
slowly disappearing a few years ago a
Korean company bought their formulas and
did the best job of faithfully
reproducing and agree
it was mixed emotions I was happy to
know that it would still be made but I
was a little disappointed that I was
less clever than I thought I was
in many ways mathematics is like
craftsmanship in some ways it's like
artistry in some ways it's like science
but there's a real car aft side to
giving a beautiful lecture on a
blackboard mathematicians admire this in
each other and like teams the best tools
for it there's incredible value to this
but the value isn't using it up not
hoarding it
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
for millions of Japanese people
springtime means one thing
baseball but what a fan probably doesn't
think about what happens to all those
broken baseball bats
well one chopsticks manufacturer as an
answer
[Music]
[Applause]
now my world up and humor Schmid's sure
level HOF Thomas Reisch a tireless name
thank you Miss Rita Nate yeah well you
got your semester put it's great the
rationalists what about the bra sizes
would be indeed a partial good study but
totally needy room as I quit tomorrow no
soon as you start a word from the eye
odometry was popular for making fine
wooden products and professional
baseball bats but because of forestry
mismanagement the species was in trouble
how about his name tomorrow my see so
could you talk audio to them another
actinides name Shimbun de que c'est
laptops now how are ya q Nova Toronto
not not lucky okay Thank You pancakes
and is named after an k0 symbol okay
that happens instead of contributing to
the problem mr. attorney had an idea
[Music]
though there has been no passion of
chiral disorder with that mr. Cattani
put his plan into motion worried about
to kill than the equity today
tengo Cola for Giovanni question what
about tonight
you know what is the path to core al
Qaeda and only morning with the profits
from these baseball chopsticks mr. irani
has joined baseball leagues and teams to
donate to a group planting a new forest
of Adamo treats infection ah Sam
Okinawan a chromo McConkey Oh tomorrow
you're shaking I see Hank you're not an
economist irony which generally catheter
- owatta chasuble serious name
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's plastic it's most likely beige and
it sounds like this chances are if you
grew up in the United States you've
played a recorder it was a non
negotiable part of your elementary
school education and for that you can
thank this guy Carl Orff a passionate
German composer originally the recorder
was handcrafted wooden and made for the
highest of society even Vivaldi and Bach
wrote pieces for the recorder it doesn't
rely on a reed or strings just breath
it's in the flute family in the 1960s
the recorders started being produced out
of plastic cheap plastic so how did it
become the clumsy awkward sound we all
used to play that's where Orff comes in
he saw the recorder as an easy way to
get kids to start playing music the
logic was simple the recorder relies on
rhythm rather than memorization if you
can sing you most likely can play it or
had the best of intentions to inspire
the next generation of musicians and
even though they can sometimes be
annoying our hats are off to you sir for
changing the course of music education
for generations to come
[Music]
let's play a game
think of a famous painting guess what
you just thought of me today I'm the
world's most renowned work of art but it
wasn't always this way my story is full
of surprises and it all began in a
studio in Florida
[Music]
well here's the master himself Leonardo
da Vinci he worked on me on and off for
a few years towards the end of his
career you're a minor work my dear some
interesting shading nothing more we'll
just see about that over the next 300
years
I hung quietly in French palaces and
royal bathrooms the things I've seen Oh
Jude until finally I was noticed by a
man who had already made quite a name
for himself when Napoleon chose me to
hang on his bedroom while people took
notice I look forward to sleeping with
you master he after he had his whole
exile from France thing they tossed me
on a wall at the Louvre but at this
point I was still just another
Renaissance portrait until one night
Menma I was stolen it was pandemonium
Paris within an uproar
the police hauled people in left and
raped the hysteria hit a fever pitch
when the police suspected and
interrogated one of the most famous
artists in the world Pablo Picasso
jacooz the Picasso was innocent
the thief turned out to be an Italian
carpenter he was cotton flooring and I
returned to the Louvre from that day
forward I became the darling of the art
world everyone wanted to see Napoleon's
da Vinci painting Picasso was suspected
of stealing soon tourists crowded in and
most people forgot why I was famous in
the first place that might raise some
eyebrows but not mine since I don't have
any oh you didn't notice I don't have
any eyebrows I told you I'm full of
surprises